make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
que paso Chico's soy Rob Ian it's the
video vamos ah hey ser algo diferente
what's going on guys this is Robin this
video we're doing okay
que paso Chico's soy rod e in este video
vamos a hacer algo diferente
okay everybody talk about what's going
on guys this is Robin we are doing
something different in this video uh we
are we're gonna cover worlds planets and
I figured what better way to cover
world's finest than to have fun when
when we're covering at least the
beginning of world's funnest now this is
a spoof comic and it's a spoof comic
based on the story of world's finest now
world's finest was a publication a DC
launched between 1941 and 1956 I think
but the overall idea was originally the
world's finest wasn't really a team-up
between Batman and Superman so much as
it was a kind of book that basically
contained both the characters now given
the cover of the comic it was basically
like 1940s clickbait it's more or less
what it was but in in in world's finest
issue number 71 that's when you first
saw Batman and Superman crossover in
that comic and the reason why was
because they had crossed over previously
in a Superman comic so at that point the
world's finest comics issue number 71
going to its conclusion basically had
Batman Superman teaming up against some
kind of villains more often than not
Batman got powers so that it wouldn't
just be like here's a guy in a bad suit
fighting alongside a guy who can do
everything right so like they they kind
of gave him powers in order to kind of
nip that in the bud but world's finest
came out is it's kind of a parody based
on that right based on the the world's
finest concept and this initially opens
up with Batman Superman and and Robin
Dick Grayson basically capturing Lex
Luthor in the Joker now as you see this
comic written
that's how world's finest was done back
then it was it was just these weird
little turns of phrase and so on and
then they were they weren't really goofy
so much as just kind of far more
lighthearted than what you see right now
it was really kind of the best way to
describe it but immediately things start
to pop off right like the bands that are
that are used to tie up Joker and Lex
Luthor a media
they come free of their own volition and
then you have like two giant mannequins
that kind of manifest and then start
tearing things up right now Superman and
Batman kind of jump into it and the
Joker seemingly subdued in a pretty
rough way right like Batman literally
jumps on the on the mannequin which
lands on the Joker's back and like
damages his spine that's all comics more
back then like keep in mind in the first
issue I think it was Batman either
Detective Comics 27 or Batman number one
I'm pretty sure it was Detective Comics
number 27 Batman hung a guy from the
batwing right so like back then it was
pretty rough like it was it was pretty
intense pretty hardcore
but of course Joker and Lex Luthor are
subdued pretty quickly well then the
question becomes how did all these
things two are manifested enter bat-mite
now that might have a pretty lengthy
history in DC comics he's been around
for a pretty good chunk of time
not nearly as long as Mixel pedelec but
he's basically the Batman equivalent of
him but as far as I understand maybe a
little less powerful I think their power
levels kind of wax and wane and sort of
changed but that's the nature of this
right this story is where you see
mixflip Italy and his most powerful but
bat-mite was basically the one who kind
of orchestrated all of this because he
wanted to see Batman and Robin in action
now that was usually the idea behind
bat-mite and that's what differentiated
him between mr. Mitchell Petula cliff
hit Alec would pop up to make Superman's
life hard right like he would just make
him go through all these riddles and
jump through all these weird hoops and
all I kind of stuff bat-mite was wasn't
really a bundling buffoon but he wanted
to see Batman in action so he would
create these weird wonky situations
where Batman and Robin would have to
cope with the various craziness that he
had now there are a couple reasons for
why DC did that the first was because
they didn't want to create a Batman
counterpart that was identical to Mixel
pedelec because when people would see
him as a cheap ripoff and they wouldn't
really care about it but the other part
of this is that where the Batman comics
were we're not exceedingly dark they
went as dark as they are now right you
weren't reading the 1940s version of
like the court of owls by Scott Snyder
but by and large there were some darker
elements like what you wouldn't see
right now but in order to kind of
lighten him up a bit as well as bring in
younger audiences we got Robin and Robin
was kind of a breath of fresh air in
this sense of like a little kid or a
younger guy fighting alongside Bruce
Wayne and so bat-mite was introduced
it's kind of that counterpart right kind
of a building on that sort of not really
happy-go-lucky but somewhat sort of
light-hearted concept now he did do some
stuff that was pretty wonky and some
stuff that was kind of dark from time to
time but if anything he's more of just a
Batman fan now around the time that
Batman appears so does mix of pedelec
and the two of them don't really have
any I mean there's no love lost
right they don't really like each other
because mix-up hillock will see bat-mite
is getting in the way of his ability to
play jokes on Superman to mess with
Superman different things like that and
so is the two of them begin to go back
and forth it gets kind of nuts right
like literally Mixel pedelec ends up
like you have this this giant sign for
some chicken restaurant or something
like that
missile pedelec brings the chicken to
life and then bat-mite turns the chicken
into like a giant cooked chicken they're
kind of countering each other's powers
and then from there of course Batman
steps in and is like look guys like you
guys got to stop you know this is gonna
gotta get out of hand and then as soon
as mixed up it'll it goes to launch a
blast against against that Mike he moves
out of the way and Batman gets hit and
so Batman dies right like he's killed by
a Mixel pedelec and like literally
bat-mite just started kind of starts
breaking down right because he's a fan
of Batman right like bat-mite is a fan
of Batman and it's crushing to see his
superhero killed in such a way also
there's there's the fact that bat-mite
recognizes the Batman so popular that DC
would lose money if they killed him
which is why DC's never killed Batman
he's too popular and he makes too much
cash that's why he always wins but
nonetheless so with that happening like
mixed pedelec slike hey man I'm sorry I
didn't really mean for it to happen and
in Superman's like ah man I can't
believe he did that and so so in
response to that that might ends up
basically manifesting this giant
magnifying glass along with it where the
red Sun is I mean Lucas he creates a red
Sun out of no and here's the thing this
is why these comics are kind of goofy if
we're talking about the actual laws of
physics in our universe the earth would
probably be ripped apart by the
gravitational pull of that Sun I mean
you could have a small red Sun like that
but the gravitational pull would be
equivalent to the Sun like to a regular
red Sun right so you're so it would it
would be insane right this is probably
lead to the creation of a black hole if
I'm being honest with you guys but
regardless this is comic books just go
with it
Neil deGrasse Tyson if you're watching
this just watch it just just have fun
man and don't analyze it but nonetheless
using this this red Sun and then this
magnifying glass it's like cooking an
ant right like literally it burns like
it shuts down Superman's powers and then
destroys right little it literally just
like burns a hole in it after that mixed
up Hitler gets pissed off so he
basically creates a giant hole puncher
and starts full punching Robin then he
turns around and takes out Lois Lane
he's like guess what girl like you're
dumb Superman was always Clark Kent and
literally creates like a giant stack of
newspapers that read Clark Kent is
Superman Lois Lane is dumb we're just
kind of funny Jimmy Olsen's like man
this sucks I'm not gonna be able to get
with like Lois Lane's sister and
he's like who cares about that man like
what a scoop Superman is Clark Kent
do that's gonna make us a boatload of
money in signals and so then from there
you have Jimmy Olsen and you have Perry
White who were killed by the giant Daily
Planet sign so then you have you have
Mixel peddler chasing after that my
trying to hit him with a newspaper right
because you kill flies with newspapers
and then here comes Supergirl
and here comes back woman and here comes
a couple other people I don't know who
they are but they're just kind of like
freaking out over the fact that like
Batman and Superman and Robin are all
destroyed and then like mixed up hit a
lick and bat-mite kind of start arguing
like who in the world did this and it's
like well you know mixed up Hitler was
the one who killed all these guys he's
like yeah but that's because you killed
Superman so yeah but you kill Batman you
know it was okay for me to do what I did
and so like at that point like all the
girls start trying and so like mixed
missile Mixel piddling she starts to get
annoyed by all their crying and so when
they asked for some tissues he manifests
a giant box of Kleenex which all
basically come pouring out and then wrap
all the girls and then basically like
suffocate them and then like they're
like Super Pets Avengers right so you
get Super Pets
from the 1919 40s and 50s now back in
the 1950s lamort Weisinger was writing
Superman they just created stuff it was
nuts there were no limits right his idea
was create something new with the
Superman mythos every six months and it
proved to be successful right like under
the ten years that weren't Weisinger was
the editor of Superman dude it was it
was the highest-selling comic DC head of
the time like this is this era right
here that you're looking at there's kind
of a spoof this was at the time when it
was Silver Age Superman when he could do
anything right Lee he had whatever he
needed at any particular time based on
what the plot called for so like it was
it was kind of nuts but like although
all the super animals are basically
taken out mixed with pedelec just
creating like super fleas they take out
like all the animals and then Joker at
Lex Luthor freaking out there having the
time of their life and so a mix of
pedelec and turn like makes Lex Luthor's
hair grow out to the point that he can't
really control it anymore starts to
strangle him and then it starts tickling
the Joker so the so Lex Luthor gets
strangled and the Joker dies of laughter
and then like mix of Hitler starts
freaking out like look what you made me
do like like who am I gonna annoy on
this planet right like I've basically
killed everybody who matters you know
and so bad nice responses well like the
Justice League is coming so like mixed
up hit like I mean you know and really
kind of even bat-mite at the same time
sort of turn on the Justice League but
it's kind of these off-color remark
right like mixed peddlers makes his
comments a Wonder Woman when he likes
smashes her with a giant flyswatter that
like your invisible jet might be
invisible but you're not and then like
the Green Lantern gets smashed by a
giant banana because back at that point
and the night
in 50s the Green Lanterns weakness was
the color yellow so it's just like oh my
god it's a banana and like that's what
kills the Green Lantern because he's
weakness to the color yellow like this
stupid and then like like the flash
trips over the banana peel and then he
lands in the end like this giant skillet
so he gets cooked alive and he dies
you know the Green Lantern basically
ends up getting got cut in half in a
mousetrap Jon Jones gets set on fire
with a giant lighter arrow gets killed
with like a giant dart Aquaman just kind
of like I gotta go man like I gotta
bounce because like I need water and and
what could he really even do anyway
right as Aquaman Aquaman sucks so like
the Legion of super-heroes up here and
they just kind of in their own existence
right because they're like we've seen
everything that you've done here and
you've destroyed all these heroes which
means it will never exist and they
disappear and then they basically just
cease to exist in the timeline and so in
effect within the span of probably about
10 minutes mr. Bixler pedelec has
basically wiped out every single super
hero on earth they're all basically gone
but that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end part 2 will
come out tomorrow if you are new here
two comments explained make sure you
guys with the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and that
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]